my name is Breanna Walden I'm a junior
here at Hillsdale College setting
political economy and it's my pleasure
to introduce the speaker tonight Johnny
Linder served as a US Representative for
the state of Georgia
prior to joining Congress representative
Linder was educated at the University of
Minnesota and served in the United
States Air Force during his time in
Congress representative Linder held a
number of leadership roles including a
ranking member of the Subcommittee on
income security and family support on
the House Ways and Means Committee from
1996 to 1998 he joined the Republican
Party leadership as chairman of the
National Republican Congressional
Committee representative Linder
sponsored the Fair Tax Act first
introducing the legislation in July of
1999 and reintroducing it in every
subsequent session he is the co-author
of the FairTax book congressman Linder
is very excited to engage in a
conversation with us this evening and
answer any questions that you have
regarding the Fair Tax so with that
please join me in welcoming Congressman
John II linger
thank you very much it's nice to be here
that stage of my life it's nice to be
anywhere I I'm going to make a few brief
comments for the last 10 years I was in
Congress I don't think I ever gave a
speech and it startled a lot of people
but I would go to a Rotary Club Rick
come on his club or Chamber of Commerce
and just say who's got the first common
question it usually startled them but I
learned more doing that than I would oh
speaking for 30 minutes and I don't
believe I've given a 30 minute speech in
my life so please be ready with
questions
I want to thank Dan Mitchell for
accommodating with flight schedule today
in switching times with me from 4:00 to
8:00 said I could be here on this
evening I want to thank him also for
putting forth this afternoon a very
serious and respectful proposal for a
tax reform the flat tax in fact I was a
sponsor of the a co-sponsor of the flat
tax back in the 90s when Dick Armey was
sponsored with sponsoring it on a
regular basis but lately I've come to a
different conclusion and I think we need
to change directions in fact the tax we
have today but you've come to know and
love is a flat tax and income 100 years
later and we flatten it out again big
time in 1986 only to have amended it
since then about 20,000 times and to
hope that future Congress is Congress's
will leave Dan's flat tax alone reminds
us of that proverbial third marriage the
victory of Hope over experience it isn't
going to happen so long as Congress
knows how much you make and how you make
it they're going to try and get the rest
I've proposed a situation that has no
idea how much you make and doesn't even
care the current system has given us a
circumstance in this country where
people in business make decisions for
tax reasons rather than economic reasons
you've been there you get up in the
morning you want to take care of your
employees your customers your
shareholders and the person at the head
of the table is a tax man with 72,000
pages of complications written by people
who have never had a customer or deploy
those decisions lead to inefficiencies
that cost money out of our pockets the
current circumstance leads us to assert
to a situation where the Tax Foundation
says that we are currently spending
between 350 and 400 billion dollars
every year just filling out IRS forms it
costs a typical small business 724
dollars to collect comply and remit $100
that isn't an inefficiency that is
stupid it's like paying for a dead horse
you get nothing for it
we have driven into the underground
economy two to three trillion dollars a
year paying nothing to our government we
have today an offshore financial centers
in dollar denominated deposits between
15 and 20 trillion dollars wanting to be
in our economy and staying offshore
because of the tax consequences of
repatriation I wants to ask Alan
Greenspan how long would it take for
that money to be in our markets in our
banks
he said months why are we continuing to
drive that money offshore last we have
today a set of circumstances that
together provide a price system that is
burdened with the 22 percent tax
component 22 percent of what you're
currently spending at retail represents
the embedded cost to the IRS you're
paying the income tax costs and the
payroll tax costs and the accountants
and attorneys to avoid the tax costs
of each of the thousands of companies it
takes to get a loaf of bread to your
table from getting oil out of the ground
to make gasoline to getting stealing or
ore out of the ground to make steel all
of those businesses have costs they have
labor cost and travel cost and tax costs
and a study out of Harvard says that the
tax component is 22% we're competing in
a global economy with a 22 percent tax
component in our price system making us
less than competitive and driving jobs
into offshore centers and the lowest
income people you always hear about
sales tax is hurting the lowest income
they're losing 22 percent of their
purchasing power today to the current
system any tax bill that nibbles around
the edges of the current income tax
system whether it's the flat tax or any
other iteration and leaves the IRS in
place doesn't touch any of those things
the fair tax fixes them all the fair tax
is a single universal at the retail
Center at the retail checkout sales tax
on the purchase of new goods and
services there's no tax on used goods we
think nothing should be taxed more than
once there's no tax on business activity
there's no tax on personal income
corporate income taxes gift tax death
tax alternative minimum tax capital
gains tax dividend tax all gone along
with the IRS currently
currently the average income earner is
giving the federal government 23 cents
of every dollar they earn 15% income tax
and 8% their share the payroll tax and
the fair tax you give the government 23%
of every dollar you spend and if you
don't spend it you're not taxed on it
all taxes are gone you get a four
trillion dollar 10-year tax cut by
getting rid of the compliance costs and
you increase the purchasing power of all
Americans through reductions in price
and increases in take-home pay but
they'll get that 22% back and we've
become a global powerhouse because we'll
be selling into a global economy without
the tax component in our price system
bill Archer when he was chairman of the
Ways and Means Committee used to quote a
study that he had seen over and over
that said a 500 phone calls were made to
international corporations whose
headquarters were in Europe or Japan and
they're asked what would you do in your
long-term planning if the United States
government eliminated all tax on capital
and labor and taxed only personal
consumption 80% said they'd build their
next plan in the United States and if
you want to know the truth if you sell
them to Detroit you'd rather be in
Detroit because the kind of the
transportation costs are immense but
because of the tax component the price
system we're not there and to make it
all fair because one of the things we
learned in the 22 million dollars worth
of private research we had done what the
American people want to make sure you
protect low income folks so we devised a
prebate system that's the rebate at the
beginning of the month not at the end
and the government transfers to every
household based not on income based on
the size of the household a distribution
sufficient to totally untaxed them on
necessities now we don't get in the
business of defining necessities I had a
friend in Congress who is a supporter
but he wanted to make sure that we
texts potatoes potato chips and not
potatoes I said that's the boat we're in
now picking winners and losers so we
took this definition of poverty level
spending which is defined as that
spending necessary for a given size
household to buy their essentials that
is a spending that we're rebating with
the prebate for household before you can
spend thirty thousand dollars with no
tax consequences beyond that everybody
pays the same we're all voluntary tax
payers and we pay taxes when we choose
as much as we choose by how we choose to
spend the fair tax bill has a provision
for getting rid of the sixteenth
Amendment we don't believe it's feasible
to do it in the bill to abolish the
sixteenth amendment requiring a
two-thirds vote but what the language
says is that if we get rid of repeal all
the taxes on income and get rid of the
IRS and seven years of enjoyment under
the Fair Tax goes by and we haven't
repealed the sixteenth Amendment and as
Dan said today aggressively repeal it
all the income taxes come back we think
that you will put enough pressure on
your members of Congress to encourage
them to eliminate sixteenth Amendment I
would hate to see what every other
nation that went to a consumption tax
has done was have a little bit of both
every every nation that starts with a
little bit of each wins up with a lot of
both and we can't get rid of one or the
other for so long as we've been taxing
individuals in this country we've only
taxed wages we've never text wealth when
Warren Buffett complains that as
Secretary was paying a higher tax rate
than he was it's because she worked for
wages first thing wealthy people do in
their lives have stopped getting wages
of on capital gains and dividends that
are taxed at a lower rate there's a
reason they're taxed at a lower rate
because you've already paid a higher
rate on them for corporate income taxes
they've been taxed twice we think that
we should be taxed
spent wealth rather than earned wages
this year the federal government is
going to get an income taxes about two
point three trillion dollars will he
believe it said I'm said we leave it
aside it that the government's gonna
spend about 1.6 trillion more than that
we'll take it up at another time but
they're gonna collect 2.3 trillion and
the FairTax would bring in 10% more than
that when they're running around
Washington looking for sources of
revenue they ought to be looking this
way we're going to come to the FairTax
one day not out of a sense that it's the
wisest thing we've ever seen but out of
the realization that there's no place
else to go the top 2% can't continue to
pay the whole bill we keep thinking that
you can just raise the tax on those very
wealthy folks but there's no money there
to speak up it's in the middle class the
other thing is it's rich folks are
pretty often smart folks when Maryland
tried a few years ago to raise some more
revenues they found 3,000 ultra high
income earners in Maryland and they
thought they'd draft a bill just to
affect them after all they had a lot of
money and they're not gonna complain
well if you a few months after that bill
passed they had 1,000 high income
earners in Maryland and I'd be surprised
if they haven't all left and you've seen
the Tres the traffic out of California
just recently the FairTax broadens the
base and lowers the rate everybody's
treated exactly the same under the Fair
Tax when that wealth of Warren Buffett
is spent and it will be spent if not by
him by his heirs or by foundations but
it'll be spent it'll be taxed at exactly
the same rate as the secretaries and
he'll be proud let me close by saying
this the Fair Tax gives to the American
people the ultimate gift that it is in
freedom's grasp to give the gift of
anonymity
never should an agency of government
know more about us and we're willing to
tell our children thank you there's the
first question
back here from your knowledge of what
the situation is what would that fair
tax rate be for 2014 if you had the
absolute hire and fire and the ability
to change the law
well the fair tax is drafted so that if
a hammer at Home Depot says ten dollars
on it
seven dollars and seventy cents goes to
Home Depot and 23 cents goes to the
federal government it's included in the
price system it's a 23% inclusive rate
it could be less than that less than
that now to be revenue neutral but I
don't have that fight today I would like
to have that fight another day
and just replace the 23% of what you're
earning with 23% of what you're spending
let this economy grow by leaps and
bronze our army research tells us that
in the first year after the fair tech
he'll have a ten point six percent
increase in the gross national product
you'll have a twenty six percent
increase in exports a seventy percent
increase in capital investment those
companies will be building plant in this
country that I can't affect that I can't
affect that but one of the first I came
to Michigan on the first visits to see
governor I talked to John Engler at
length of the governor's that I've
spoken with of which been several maybe
ten or twelve over the years all of them
fixed there that have that all of them
and have a income tax fix it to the
federal income tax but we think they do
is fix their sales tax as an inclusive
tax get rid of all exclusions and
exemptions tax goods and services we did
a study in 1997 I think it was in Texas
and there eight and a quarter percent
sales tax would have been arrested
reduced to two and a quarter percent and
raised the same amount of revenue if it
was a conclusive tax and all goods and
services with no exclusions or
exemptions we think they'll do that
thank you for speaking mr. Mitchell said
earlier that he saw the flat tax as a
transitional tax on the road to
something else do you see this along
those same lines or differently no I
don't I see this is a as in terminal
station if we can get rid of the tax on
income and go a tax on spending I think
that's as far and get rid of exclusions
and exemptions we have to trust the
American people not to let you raise it
and let you keep changing it the current
system is such that the last four or
five tax events have been promised to
you that work will only increase the tax
in the top two percent and the other 98
percent said go get them I want the next
tax increase to have a reason for it
that's so compelling that you're willing
to pay it and willing to raise your
taxes I think a lot of Americans would
keep pressure on Congress not to let it
be raised
thank you for comment sir I have an
excerpt here from a gentleman named
Bruce Bartlett
he was a Treasury official under the
first president Bush so I'd like to read
this excerpt I know Bruce and I expect
this is not a very favorable comment I
would like to hear what your take is on
his criticism here he says one
consequence of the Fair Tax is to
penalize those who are young you may
need to borrow and consume heavily to
establish themselves by buying their
first cars first homes and all the
furnishings that go with them and
possibly to pay for the cost of child
rearing as well he goes on to say it
also penalized us those who are older
who have saved for the retirement during
an era when saving was heavily penalized
by the income tax but rather than being
able to spend their savings tax-free as
they have anticipated they will now have
to pay sales tax and everything they buy
including healthcare how was in now I'll
get to that I was in Arizona doing talk
radio in the FairTax several years ago
and a lady from Sun City was driving in
her car toward the city I think it was
Phoenix but I was in and she called in
she said I hate your tax she said I paid
taxes and income my husband I paid the
tax we sold a business and now you're
going to tax us once more we spend it I
made a mistake of saying consider your
grandchildren she said I don't give a
damn about my grandchildren I care about
me the fact of the matter is she's
already paying this tax it's already
embedded in the price of everything she
buys the the people are going to be
wounded by this are people who have Roth
IRAs because they've already paid the
tax on that if you have a regular IRA
that's not a Roth IRA you'll be able to
take your money out of your IRA with no
tax consequences but the fact of the
matter is we are a generational taxed
nation to think that we can look at one
set of people and say okay here's how
it's going to impact you is not a way to
look at the overall tax circumstance
because it's a generational tax the fact
is that young people are currently going
to pay for us the way it is
if they buy new homes that prices
already built into the cost of that new
house if they buy used things there's no
tax on used things everybody's gonna
make different decisions but this is
going to give you the opportunity to be
a voluntary tax payer and I'm gonna
benefit personally because I've got
everything I own paid for it and I was
just at to pay taxes on my food gasoline
but I want to give everything to my kids
and they're gonna spend it and they're
gonna pay tax on it
at the same rate I would if I if I spent
it so Bartlett also says that the
genesis of this program was came from
Scientology I think it was I've never
met a Christian not Scientologists I
guess it was I've never met one and I've
been there from the beginning so I I
don't put a lot of stock in everything
he says
one advantage that I I see about the
sales tax if the rate gets too high
people always have the option of not
buying things whereas if the rate gets
too high on income tax they don't they
don't have the option of not working and
and my question is what do you do about
the resistance you'll have with the
internet crowd are you gonna have the
state sales tax agencies collect this or
is the or will the businesses report to
the federal government the states the
state's collected and remitted to the
federal government forty five states are
currently collecting its sales tax
they've got the mechanism in place they
got the fraud mechanisms in place better
than we could possibly build at the
federal level would pay them a quarter
of a basis point for doing that or
twenty five base a quarter of a percent
twenty five basis points for doing that
would pay the retailer 25 basis points
for collecting it but it's collected at
the state level and remitted to the
federal government the federal
government would have one division that
would collect taxes on catalog and
internet sales I think we should tax
internet sales for this reason if you
got a guy down the street who's build a
brick building in your neighborhood and
he hires your kids and buys in your
community and goes to your church in
your rotary commit a club and committed
commits to the community why should he
be at a 7% disadvantage to to amazon.com
I think that she'd all be treated the
same which shouldn't be picking winners
and losers as to whether there'll be
less consumption when the tax gets too
high I will point out that the
consumption base in this country from
going back to the early 30s has been a
fairly consistent base it has it has
none of the amplitudes of volatility
that the income base has for example
right now we have no corporate taxes to
speak of and a lot of people laid off
not paying income taxes and tax revenues
are down dramatically I think they're
collecting about 15% down would that be
fair of the GDP in taxes 16 maybe and
it's typical to collect 18 or 19 it's a
big big swing so the consumption tax
doesn't have those amplitudes of
volatility
and we markets it's a more steady
predictor of economic activity than as
income my question has to do with the
prebate that you're talking about
in dealing with the poorer segments of
the population that they would have no
no no we're not dealing with poor
section all you're gonna get this
prebate you've signed up with your
Social Security Department with it and
how many people live in the house and
the prebate will be sent to you probably
through a debit application debit card
or through like they're doing EBT now
you will get your cash distribution at
the beginning the month based on how
many people in the house because we're
not going to know how much you make or
how you make it
so the if low income people are making
or spending $25,000 a year for a family
of three just to live that portion of it
will be untaxed but if the wealthy Bill
and Melinda Gates one on the lip moved
to the farm and spent ten thousand
dollars a year to to exist they'll be
untaxed to the prebate goes based on the
size of the household not the amount of
income and household okay so it it's
just across the board
yes it's praevia talking about nobody
should pay taxes on necessities the only
reason we use poverty level is to define
what the level of spending on
necessities is and for family for that
comes according to this year's this
year's federal government I just adjust
meant it's thirty thousand dollars a
year they'll be able to spend that
untaxed because of their prepay
they'll pay the tax so just get the
money in advance to cover okay thank you
much for your presentation I have a
question how are you gonna collect from
cash based businesses beauty shops
restaurants gas stations party stores
that historically under report their
income in fact their sales equal their
expenses and any promise let's start out
with the premise that we're Americans
that we cheat but under the current
system all you have to do is lie in your
tax return and you get less than a 1%
chance of being caught under this system
you have to have two people conspire to
cheat no I don't know how many friends
you have willing to go to jail to help
you out with a few pennies but I have
none we have interestingly we we have
about a thirty three hundred forty five
billion dollar tax gap that's tax
returns that are sent in with the
admission of the debt that isn't paid
isn't remitted and if you go through the
whole system you find out that the
federal government's collecting about 72
to 75 percent of what they know is owed
under the sales tax the vast majority of
the money eighty eight percent of the
money on the goods side is gonna be
collected by the big-box stores I don't
know who you know what Lowe's or Home
Depot but I don't know anybody's gonna
help me on the on the goods on the
services side the vast majority of the
of the taxes are gonna be collected by
medical profession and they have
licenses to be concerned about so I
think you're gonna have less if we just
collected the 72 to 75 percent we'd have
more money in the bank than we have
under the current system but we will
have cheaters I promise you that sir you
expressed a great deal of confidence
that the American people would prevent
Congress from getting out of hand with
the sales tax either in terms of rage or
specialisations or so on but that it
seems to be very similar to that which
we have not been doing by your own words
with the income tax as things have been
changed over the years what is the
basis for your great confidence as
regards to the sales tax versus the
income tax George Bush tax increase of
1989 to 90 the Bill Clinton tax increase
of 93 the most recent tax increase
you've seen all taxes have been promised
only to affect the top 2% of the
American people and the other 98% said
it's not going to affect me why do I
care
really great Russell long line don't tax
him don't tax me tax that man behind the
tree the American people if they're not
gonna be they don't think they can be
affected they just walk off to raise the
nationwide universal sales tax by one
cent it's going to affect you and
everyone you know and you're going to
have a keener interest in it than under
the current circumstance thank you very
much
under the Obamacare law they are getting
16,000 more IRS agents to collect the
various wonderful taxes in that law
which are tremendous if you have a
national sales tax how do you get the
Obamacare law modified so you don't have
those agents doing the collecting and
you don't have that specific source of
income for that specific service it is
my fondest hope that it will collapse of
its own weight I emailed several of my
colleagues or former colleagues when
these discussions are kind of about and
they were putting bills forth to repeal
Obamacare and I said what you need to do
is change the subject
and get the American people interested
in a national sales tax and let
Obamacare fall of its own weight I don't
believe that those taxes that they're
not all taxes after John Roberts
I don't believe those sacks are gonna be
sufficient to pay the bill I think it's
I don't believe it'll be efficiently
collected I don't I think that entire
thing will fall of its own weight and I
really don't care
dr. Mitchell spoke today about the
importance of a simplified tax system
and the importance of taxing things that
are in the United States territory if we
impose a sales tax upon businesses on
the internet where does American
territory stop and other countries
territory begin well we have 50 states
and and five territories and I think
that's American territory I don't
understand if if people are collecting
if people are selling though to American
citizens in our country they're going to
have to collect the tax when we first
started this retailers came to me and
said there's no way to do this and I
said well Sears has been doing it for 60
years if they sell catalog sales into a
state in which they are accounting for
Victor if they have a business they have
to collect that they have to collect the
sales tax for the state on it
so they're gonna have to collect the tax
thank you our speaker earlier that this
afternoon told it the story of an event
where he was speaking to what he thought
was a friendly group and turned out he
was in the den of lions your proposition
as well as his has a huge vested
interest in keeping things complex
armies of tax attorneys and CPAs and IRS
agents and all the rest of the how do
you fight that battle we believed when
we first started this in the 90s and
introduced in 99 that we'd never win
this battle in Washington DC
we'd have to win it in Michigan and in
Minnesota and Georgia and Mississippi
and we have volunteer organizations in
every state now where the volunteers
from Michigan are right here at least
three three folks and four folks and the
American people once they catch onto
this will move Congress Congress always
moves according the American people I
was giving a talk to a group of
accountants who were specialists in the
tax code and one of them who was an old
friend of mine when I get finished with
the whole thing he said John just give
me a couple more years in fact they hate
it John snow came to see me for a second
visit on this when he was still
Secretary of Treasury and I said John
where you been I said I know what
happened to you the last time you were
here
I said you went back to the Treasury and
I won't use her name but she was
Assistant Secretary of Treasury for tax
policy
I said she beat the hell outta you all
the way back to the Treasury Department
because you're even thinking about this
and he left it said yeah that's true I
said well she's now making a million
dollars a year of gaming the code the
fact of the matter is we can't move
Washington you have to move the people
and the people of Washington we listen
far more keenly to our constituents than
we do the law being a lobbyist said the
easiest people say no to in the world
because it's our business to
knows as well as yeses but you can't say
that very easily to your constituents
and when we moved the country and it's
moving you can't be a congressman and
very and very many places of the country
without getting questions and your town
hall meetings about the Fair Tax send up
their Michigan's for fair taxation
let me yeah yeah he's an accountant let
me let me say something about
accountants accountants make a lot more
money sitting down with their clients
and charting the future than I do
recording the past and I haven't had an
accountant yet complain to me about
losing business
they worked 16 18 hour days for three
months a year just trying to figure out
a code that some of the regulations have
not even been written for yet and
signing their name to the bottom of the
tax return so I'm not the least bit
worried about them the people who make a
living off it in Washington don't like
it at all and the members of Congress
who listen to them a lot will not ever
move on this until a year from their
constituents but we do listen to our
constituents thank you you indicated I
can't hear you oh excuse me you
indicated that the states that have a
state income tax would collect money for
the federal government no sales tax the
sales tax excuse me does that mean that
the states would incent in a sense
control the purse strings for the
federal government and would that give
them leverage over the federal budget
deficit spending and the federal debt
and that sort of no no they would just
be a license to collect our portion was
their portion and send it in speaking
just on the constituents point it makes
sense that the constituent or you would
listen to your constituents what happens
when the constituents don't know what
they want or are not sure of or
understand the tax code one of the
things mr. Mitchell talked about we're
not doing a good enough job of educating
people on how these taxes work how would
you go about educating or properly
moving the people as it were he's
correct we're not doing a good enough
job of educating but most of America
understands the sales tax they see it in
45 states they sit they pant and they
walk away from it I don't go back and
recapture the receipts fill out tax
returns
they don't do it they don't spend with
their fellow Americans eight billion man
hours a year 78 million man hours a year
just filling out paperwork they
understand it and if they were given the
opportunity to choose between them I
believe they choose a tax system where
they could control how much they're
willing to pay you mentioned that the
fair tax would stop all the other taxes
such as a corporate tax or a capital
gains tax from existing any tax based on
income would be gone what safeguards
would the fair tax put in place to
prevent that from happening in the
future I mentioned earlier on that we
have a provision in the bill first of
all the bill just repeals all the taxes
and gives you a different paradigm a
consumption based tax versus an
income-based tax and then the bill says
that if the if it's seven years Congress
doesn't pass a repeal of the sixteenth
amendment all the other taxes come back
into play and the sales tax goes away we
think that's the closest incentive we
can get we can't mandate future Congress
to do anything or States to pass it but
that's the best incentive we can think
of tuition so would they have to force
some sort of some form of convention or
you just kind of hoping that they'll
ignore the sixteenth amendment
well Congress if the American people
will get up in arms the Congress will
act and there is a proposal right now
going about to use article four article
5 of the Constitution to have a
constitution convention for the sole and
exclusive purpose of posing the fair tax
if that gets any legs and starts move
the people in Congress not wanting to
lose that clout and the control over
this will move Congress can pass with
the two-thirds vote a change in the
Constitution it still has to be ratified
by the states and that's it but but the
flat tax is going to take a
constitutional change also not to pass
it but to keep it because every time we
tried to flatten it out future
congresses of
it's back into as bad a shape as who
were before so ultimately the people are
gonna have to speak on this you very
much I guess my question is and it kind
of bored us on exactly what you're
talking about now how do you ensure
Congress is going to keep and limit what
it can do we've trusted them to keep
their promises in the past and we're in
the mess we are now so how do we stop it
in the future well we are a free society
and you get to vote every two years if
the American people want to vote for
this that's their pride I think it's
wrong
I was stunned when they voted to keep
President Obama in place but they did
and we can't change that if future count
in future elections put in place that
Congress is willing to double the tax
rate and the American people think
that's a good idea it's their idea and
they get to do it we cannot put
constraints on what the American people
can do as much as we would like to with
us tonight over the past few years we've
heard with Occupy Wall Street and other
movements about the 1% and the rich and
the 47% and all these numbers and I'm
just wondering how the Fair Tax
addresses the appeal of class warfare or
if that's not a an issue that needs to
be addressed it's just the opposite of
that it doesn't pick winners and losers
it treats everybody exactly the same
everybody Bill Gates and you for your
family gonna get that distribution to UM
tax you on necessities and you're all
gonna pay the same above that it doesn't
pick winners or losers
thank you so much for speaking tonight I
love the majority of the policy effects
predicted under the FairTax however as a
limited government constitutional
conservative I'm completely appalled by
the psychology of sending a government
check to every household in America
every every month has any effort been
made to find another way to untaxed
necessities hi I'm in favor of changing
the tax code there have been many
proposals in the past none of that has
many sponsors as fair tax has which
started out this year with 52 sponsors
but the only way we accomplished solving
the questions that I raised at the
beginning the tax decision versus
economic decisions for business the
embedded cost at retail of the current
tax code the compliance costs the
underground economy the offshore economy
the only thing you can fix those is get
rid of getting rid of the IRS and the
only proposal that I've seen to totally
rid of the IRS is a fair tax I'm sorry I
didn't hear that I meant as part of the
fair tax plan to get rid of the check
monthly to people I meant as a total
package the Fair Tax is there a way to
do it without having that monthly check
from the government to households that
is an argument that would take about
eight percent off the cost of the tax if
we didn't have that prebate system going
to households but what we found in our
in our research on it was the American
people wanted to provide protection for
a role particularly compete on the
purchase of necessities we felt we
should protect everybody on the same way
so we did get into picking winners and
losers yeah you can all worry about this
on FairTax org but more importantly you
can go and get the bill it's 132 pages
you can actually read it and it makes
sense please do that
how the sales tax would be implemented
for non-physical goods especially those
I guess it would it apply to some of
those such as buying stocks if there's
no tax on income let's say I want to go
by an insurance policy or some of these
more abstract kind of financial
constructs I can put my money into what
a sales tax apply to those non-physical
it would apply to the service portion of
the cost of doing so and the bank that
wants to make you the loan would have to
calculate what the service portion of
making that loan is and charge you the
sales tax on it not the whole loan the
service portion in the of running the
casino in Las Vegas not how much you won
but how much did you incur in terms of
service costs and providing the chips
you have a question about tax brackets
now one of the issues with current tax
brackets is that people who are in a low
income tax bracket as soon as they step
out of that bracket into a higher one
the marginal tax rate that they'd have
to pay on their new income will
disincentivize them to earn more money
with the prebate Act at all like a tax
racket would it incentivize low
consumption families to continue
spending under they debate level the
pre-baked is based on the number of
people in the household not the income
level of the household and we're not
going to have any agency in the federal
government owes what your income is so
there's there is simply since everyone
is getting it there's no class warfare
there's no brackets everybody's getting
the same treatment well yes my question
is is if they want to spend more than
what they would be required to spend for
necessities well the fact that they're
getting a prebate incentivize them to
not spend more than say the $30,000 that
the prebate allows them to spend on
taxed I expect that that differs with
every human being in America some will
spend more and some won't and it's not
our business to know why or care why
upon the idea of the constituency
driving Washington to move to a fair tax
just wondering how I would convince my
kids that this is a good idea none of
them is really aware of how much they
pay an income tax no it's withheld and
once a year they think about it I'm
gonna get that check back oh well maybe
but maybe you just mentioned the quarter
or the the monthly rebate check that
might soften the blow but I can see that
take a lot of education to the
constituents to say this is how much you
really pay an income tax are day by day
so that when you start to spend yours
your national sales tax they bite they
it won't seem like this is a whole new
poverty stream a new approach to poverty
and the government taking even more than
you really thought you paid before I'm
not in the business of trying to educate
kids and how much to make my son when he
started work was furious how much that
mr. fry command took out of his check
for the first two months and he got
thrilled when he got a check back in
April I believe the average income
earner is going to get about 30 to 40%
increase in take-home pay the dad for
this passes and I think they're going to
appreciate that and they're gonna be
more concerned about how that where that
money comes from and how we just can't
you know there's a guy knock in where he
got one time who tried to do what you
would like to do and as Friday came and
he paid every Friday and it had his
workers come by this table and he gave
them the money for their for their pay
and then next saw was how much they're
taking up for Social Security and then
how much taken up for Medicare and the
government shut him down now I'm going
to tell you something that it's painful
to me to admit but one of the people
most intimately involved in withholding
in World War two was the beloved Milton
Friedman they believed at the time that
was the only way to go
while we're stuck with it we're stuck
with and I think giving people the full
check one time will open some eyes but
we can't delay moving hoping that we
could educate a realized person because
we can thank you for coming tonight sir
we're just thinking about your FairTax
here and about how you're saying certain
Goods will be exempt because there needs
no no I mean I mean this is one of the
toughest things to explain guys
nothing is exempt nothing exempt the
federal government every year sets a
number but it says it would cost the
household of one to four or eight X
number of dollars to pay for their
essentials
it's called poverty level spending and
that's the number we use to send you
your check but we don't pick out
essentials we don't define them we don't
pick winners and losers we send you a
check
based on the government statistic or the
government number established every
January I guess as to what you need to
spend in your household to pay for your
essentials you might take that check
every year and go to the door every
month and all the dog track not my
problem
I misunderstood thank you not my problem
I was taught that it's not a good idea
to go to your barber and ask if you need
a haircut
within the context of that statement I
would ask you how do you address the
question of would you go to your barber
and ask him to pay the taxes the service
industry raises this issue all the time
and my answer to them is in fact this
came up in a talk before a group about
the size of physicians from California
in Washington DC and we'd been talking
for about 45 minutes until one physician
throughout and she said what you expect
me to tax my patients and I said what
makes you think you're so special all
your neighbors are taxing their source
of income every day to pay for the
government why shouldn't you those
service people particularly service
people have an embedded cost of their
tax embedded in their prices is more
than 22 percent they're already paying
this they'll come up money ahead and
they won't spend fortunes with tax
planning as they get older because there
will be no tech no death tax question
are there any examples of any
governments who have implemented a pure
fair tax system I know you mentioned
that there were several mixed systems
but can you think of any actual of
station no I don't know and I'd be
surprised if there were any because
every nation that one to addict and most
of the consumption taxes added are
value-added taxes which I'm particularly
opposed to because although it's a very
efficient way as Milton Friedman said
it's the most efficient way to raise
taxes it's also the most effective way
to increase the size of the government
and so I'm opposed to that but most of
the nations have gone to a value-added
tax and they've added on top of their
income tax to the point where in Europe
it's typically they're typically taxed
in 40 percent of the GDP
he's compared to our 20-plus percent
twenty 2829 the used Goods would be
untaxed once you once you've bought in
the item it's been taxed as a new item
but how does that work in the industry
where you mentioned that Amazon sales on
Amazon would be taxed equally as a new
good I'm a seller I still used books on
Amazon I pay the michigan state sales
tax I have a sales tax license for that
business but how would that how would
you differentiate many of the online
sales such as eBay and Amazon there are
regular people on there selling their
goods every day so how would you
regulate the the difference between the
used goods aren't oil to online versus
the new goods sold online I think I
think we can ask the people who are
selling them if they're you used or new
and we can have the audit system like we
have an income taxes to find out if
people are lying and punish those that
are we look I can't say this off enough
for Americans we cheat some people gonna
cheat on this some people but but you
know what there's probably one or two
people in this room that have a
corporate credit card or have had a
corporate credit card and drove that car
and that gas to pick up their kids at
school
that's cheating wasn't for corporate
business so we're gonna cheat but we're
gonna catch it if we if we just collect
what we know us do we'll collect better
than the IRS is like today
what are we going to do about grants and
subsidies what grants and subsidies
grants oh we don't this doesn't affect
spending this bill only affects the
method used to raise the revenues it
doesn't have anything to do with how the
revenues are spent which is another big
challenge let me know sorry about that
let me know if I heard you correctly
that prices should not increase because
the embedded cost of the current tax
system is about the same as the cost of
the fair as the amount of the fair tax
that's the first question let me deal
with that one one thing every
businessman I know is going to try and
keep that price in there but competition
they're gonna let him do it first
computer I bought was a used computer it
filled the closet in the office it cost
me $12,000 the last one I bought was 20
times as fast 20 times as powerful and
cost me $500 why don't they just keep
charging me twelve thousand this
competition won't let them keep the
price in there it'll drive it out
because they're gonna eliminate their
share of the payroll tax they're gonna
limonade all of their embedded costs and
there and most businesses are very
anxious to get market share and they do
that by lowering prices
what's your next one okay second
question is is there a constitutional
issue in terms of federalism in getting
and having this in the federal
government's requiring the states to
collect a national sales tax we don't
require the states to grow to collect it
we pay them if they do but we've had
several states come into this discussion
and said if you find any state that
doesn't want to collect the sales tax in
their state such as the states that do
not currently have it we'll be happy to
do it for them for that 25 basis points
okay thank you are you going to what
about payroll taxes what happens to
Medicare and Social Security payroll tax
is the most onerous tax most regressive
tax there is in America and it's gone
final question is home sales yes is
there going to be there will be a sales
tax on new homes but presumably not on
used homes correct and what do you
expect the impact on the housing market
to be it depends on what city you're in
it's gonna change all of this stuff is
going to be difficult there no but there
are no transition rules only one
transition rule in the bill and there
will be some dislocations there's no
question about that the transition rule
is if you're a builder or a such as a
builder of homes and you have a bunch of
inventory on hand on the 20 31st of
December the value of that inventory can
be used as a credit against collecting
the tax in the next year because you've
already paid the taxes in those that
equipment in that resources that you
used to build those homes any business
that has inventory on hand at the end
December can be used that value that
inventory as a credit to not collecting
taxes on the new sales until it's used
up in the next year and there are no
other no other transition rules in the
entire bill this will be our final
question thanks so much for speaking
with us my question is it appears that
the Occupy Wall Street movement and a
lot of those on the Left are pushing
their agenda using the argument of
justice and what's what's the most just
system I'm wondering if your
foundational argument for switching to a
tax on consumption versus income is one
of efficiency or creating better
incentives or if it could be argued from
fundamentally a position of what's most
Justin and how we can can we present
that argument to the American people any
time I hear someone use the word justice
I assume they're coming from the left
and they're trying to put something over
on me
this is just I don't know anybody who
knows what's just we've learned in the
Obamacare Supreme Court decision that
justice did not hold a very steady hand
so I just want to I want a tax bill that
raises the same amount of revenue but
doesn't put us through so many
contortions to get there every person in
this room who is paid an income tax is a
criminal because we've paid something
that we didn't or we didn't pay
something we should have and we've done
it wrong because half they're not half
but very large numbers of the
regulations following tax bills are not
written when you have to fill you file
your tax returns
I want to system where you go to a store
choose whether or not you want to buy
that product with the taxes embedded in
it you know what it is when you walk out
it's over it's all over in April 15th is
another nice spring day thank you